hey everybody here thank you for
sticking around until the end of the day
I know lots of people are sort of
skipping out on the last round of talks
to catch planes or trains or flights or
buses or whatever else you're getting
too so appreciate you sticking around
title this talk is developing developing
an expression language for quantitative
financial modeling so this is about a
tool that we've built as cuanto peon
into an open source library we maintain
called zip line which is sort of the
core of our back testing engine the
slides for this will be posted
afterwards at my github so it's github
com s sanderson PI data NYC 2015 there
are very old versions of the slides from
like four days ago posted right there so
I don't necessarily recommend you follow
along but they'll be posted up there if
you want to look at them after
afterwards so a little bit about me this
is a picture of me wearing a tie so I'm
an engineer at cuanto peon I work on a
whole bunch of things but one of the
hats that I wear is that I'm the lead
designer for our API so it's my job to
sort of maintain the conceptual
integrity of the back testing platform
we put out so the core thing that we
work on is a tool for people to show up
and write trading items in the browser
in Python and my primary responsibility
is sort of thinking about what
abstractions that back tester should
present to our users what are the actual
like functions what are they named were
they called but more importantly sort of
what are the conception the concepts
underlying those and how should you
think about implementing trading
algorithms in our framework and again
all this stuff is powered by zip line
which is an open-source librarian of the
hood you can find me on twitter and
github at these places and sort of my
background is actually in mathematics
and philosophy but fair amount of
computer science in there as well so
this is going to be a mixed sort of half
of this is gonna be very conceptual talk
and half this is going to be a very like
nuts and bolts this is how we actually
made the bits do the thing we wanted
them to do so the outline here we're
going to talk briefly about trading API
design what is the training algorithm
how should you think about training
algorithms at least in the framework
that we're going to be building here one
of the things that's going to that's
going to fall out of that is I'm going
to argue that symbolic computation is a
really powerful idiom for designing
high-level api's that are still
performant enough to work on the kinds
of data that we want to be working on
I'm going to demo the thing that we've
actually built that I'm talking about
and then talk about some of the specific
technical challenges that come with
designing powerful api's for working on
financial data with
has its own fun quirks and
idiosyncrasies that make it a
particularly challenging domain to work
on so what is training algorithm if you
google for trading our rhythm designs
you get a whole bunch of boxes and
arrows that I can't imagine mean
anything to anyone so one of the things
I like to think about for any program is
every program you've ever written is a
function from the current state of the
world to side effects right so hello
world in python is a function from the
contents of your standard in buffer and
it has side effects that writes things
into standard out in the context of a
trading algorithm we have fairly
specific world state and fairly specific
side effects so the state that we care
about is our current portfolio at any
given time data about the particular
assets that we're training so that can
be things like price and volume data
fundamental values so earnings shares
outstanding that sort of thing and
there's sort of this long tail of exotic
data that people are trying to
incorporate into fundamental or into
trading algorithms and then you also
have data that's not necessarily
meaningfully tied to a particular asset
so things like oil prices and
unemployment and the u.s. GDP and that
sort of thing and then our side effects
are orders and cancellations right so I
take in all this data and I decide I now
want to own some acid or I now don't
want to own Samantha and that's those
are basically our side effects so one of
the things I like to think about a lot
is that good API is encourage people to
decompose problems in a way that's
appropriate for the domain so a good API
encourages you to think about concepts
the right way in a way that is going to
encourage you to you know have your have
various pieces of your code have
separated concerns and they're going to
be able to allow you to think about
different elements of your strategy or
different almonds in whatever you're
doing in a way that you don't have to be
constantly sort of thinking about
everything at once you want to be able
to break down problems into smaller and
smaller pieces until everything you're
doing seems simple and so we have this
large problem right if we want to look
at the state of the world and based on
that place orders we can for most
trading algorithms break that down into
two pieces so we're going to say you
know given the data that we've just seen
what what positions do we want to hold
like what's our desired portfolio if we
could just wave a magic wand and hold
whatever positions we ever wanted to
hold and then the second piece is okay
given what we want to hold and give it
what we currently hold how are we going
to place orders to move us from point A
to point B in the API that I'm going to
be talking about today is primarily
focused on solving this first problem of
how do we take all the different kinds
of data that we might care about a
trading algorithm and compute portfolio
waits for them and we can break that
problem down even further so we're going
to choose the input data that were
actually going to use to do our
computations we're going to decide what
valleys we actually want to compute so
generally ultimately we're going to end
up with one number per asset so
somewhere along the way we're going to
take this you know very
multi-dimensional data and we're going
to be reducing it down to single values
so generally we're performing numerical
reductions things like mean you know
moving average exponential moving
averages that sort of thing or maybe
just you know take the last value from
some trailing window often we care about
sort of excluding different kinds of
assets or different kinds of data so
we're often sort of taking boolean masks
and saying you know this data is missing
or I don't want to care about assets
that didn't trade over some period of
time and then a third sort of slightly
more advanced concept is we often care
about sort of bucketing or bidding
different kinds of data into different
groups so things like I want to group
assets by the industry that the company
trades in or I want to partition up the
universe of assets by like des iles or
quartiles of market cap so we're going
to you know compute all these different
kinds of reductions produce individual
values and we want to be able to combine
and compare these things so we take away
the combinations we do ranking we do
filtering we do various kinds of
normalization many of these atomic
computations especially from that sort
of first top section here share a common
structure where we're going to get the
last n periods worth of data where
sometimes n is just one right sometimes
you just want the most recent value of
some fundamental factor say and then
were going to apply a reduction to
produce a single valued output for each
asset and there's three sort of core
kinds of expression that often get used
so there's a factor is a little bit of
an overloaded term and in the financial
domain but the way that we use it in our
system is it just means sort of any
computation on trailing windows of data
that's going to produce a numerically
valued result filters are the same thing
for the chilling windows that are
producing boolean value results and then
classifiers are things that are
producing categorically valued results
and sort of one of the interesting
things that falls out of that is that we
can compose these different kind of
computations differently right so if I
have two computations that produce
numbers well i can add those together
and have a new computation which is the
result of doing the previous two
computations and then adding together
the result element
and that sort of leads us naturally to
thinking about how can we sort of design
a language for describing the
composition of these different atomic
elements and so sort of going into a
little bit more detail on examples
factors or numerical value things common
examples are mean and median first last
standard deviation factors can be added
subtracted multiplied to divide they can
also do some more interesting things so
if I have some factor which is
conceptually a big block of numerical
data I can do things like rank assets so
you know take moving averages of every
asset and you know rank them by the
difference between that and some other
moving average is like a very classic
intro like hello world for a training
algorithm and you can also do sort of
more advanced things like Z scoring or
normalization by various kinds of
interesting statistical metrics filters
again computations producing boolean
valued results most commonly they're the
result of some sort of comparison so you
want to say you know I don't care about
assets whose volume was below some value
or I don't care about assets where
earnings dates were you know more than
five days before or after now something
like that and again we can compose these
together but by you know our boolean
operators you and and or and we can also
use them as masks for computations like
rank or percentile where you want to say
rank all assets by some criterion but
ignore assets that didn't meet some
other criteria that's often a very
important way to be thinking about these
computations and then classifiers
categoricals you know if i have two
different ways of bucketing up my
universe i can think about the cross
product of those where I have all the
values that were bucketed in by one
scheme and then another scheme and I can
sort of multiply those out into a matrix
and then most commonly these are useful
for grouping by in order to
normalization so I can do things like
you know compute adjusted earnings for
all these assets and then subtract out
the mean of each assets sector Sarah its
industry and that's a way of making sure
that when you're doing comparisons
you're doing comparisons between
companies they're in some sense similar
and so we have these sort of three ideas
of different kinds of computations that
we're going to do and we can use that to
think about the sort of platonic ideal
of an algorithm that we might want to
design an API for and so the algorithms
that were going to sort of be targeting
and enabling our algorithms which are
going to look at you know every asset in
some large known universe looking look
at trailing windows of data compute
these filters factors and classifiers
and we're going to compose meta
expressions out of those and then use
ult we will use the outputs from those
meta expressions to compute desired
portfolio allocations and then not
really worrying about this here but
ultimately any algorithm that's doing
this would then be taking those in
deciding how to actually distribute its
capital to the particular assets that
they care about and some sort of devil
design goals these are just sort of
general designs for any kind of API I
think but so you want to make it easy to
share and reuse things that you use in
multiple places you wanna make it easy
to compose transformations in ways that
would seem natural for what they're
doing you want to be performing enough
that you can actually operate on all
this data without you know being
unpleasant to use your having to like
you know scale up a giant cluster in
order to do a simple back test and you
want to be abstract enough that the
underlying machinery can be changed
without breaking lots of API is this is
a particularly important thing for us at
cuanto pian because we take other
people's code and like run their trading
algorithms with it and so if we break
api's then that can potentially we
either have to stop people's algorithms
or you know move them to do a vent
server that's using an old
infrastructure something like that so
it's it's hard for us to safely change
the behavior of code out from under
people so we spend a lot of time
thinking about how can we design things
that are abstract enough that we can
change them without breaking them and so
given all those different sort of design
goals I'm going to argue that symbolic
computation is the right way to think
about this problem and I think
increasingly what we're seeing in the PI
data community especially is that
symbolic computation is how high level
API is to performant code are going to
be written and I think they're sort of a
bunch of reasons why symbolic
computation is really powerful idiom and
by symbolic computation or deferred
computation what I mean our frameworks
where you're not operating directly on
your data right so in numpy I build up
an umpire ray and I just have a thing
that's basically just a buffer of data
and anything that I do with it has to
sort of respect the semantics of Python
so if I have an array and I do array
plus array plus R a plus or a Python
dictates that that has to be strict and
so it has to be creating an array and
then throwing it away and then creating
an array and throwing it away because it
has this sort of chain of how it does
the binary operators and it's constantly
creating a throwing away temporary or is
and so even in the last two or three
years we've seen the sort of explosion
of libraries that are trying to do some
all computations we haved ask
blaze I this fiano just two days ago
Google announced tensorflow is another
library that is very similar to all
these things so all these libraries are
built on this idea that you don't
operate directly on data which you
operate on our symbolic or abstract
representations of data and then you
give that to some execution context and
let that execute your code and there's a
bunch of benefits that come from that
kind of a framework right so there's
optimizations that we can only do when
we have sort of a view of the whole
computation if we're doing everything
eagerly as soon as we do an expression
then we don't ever get to see the whole
computation in its entirety and so we
can't do things like eliminate common
sub-expressions or cash or pre-compute
pure functions or do certain kinds of
term rewritings right so if I if I'm
doing some sort of computer algebra
system and I do a plus a plus a well
modulo like floating point weirdness I
can maybe rewrite that as three times
and that's potentially going to be
faster there's also benefits to
abstraction right so the framework can
change you know if the frameworks API is
I just give you some symbolic
computation and then say run it I don't
really care how that happens under the
hood as long as it gives me the right
result at the end and so it gives
language designers a lot more freedom to
change how things work under the hood as
long as they preserve the output
semantics and this leads to frameworks
that can support multiple execution
styles or multiple execution context
right so blaze for example is a library
that can take these abstract expressions
and say execute this expression against
sequel or execute this expression
against an umpire or execute this
expression against you know some data
set that you've never heard of and ask
is another example that's where I can
take you know this abstract
representation of computation but then
say run single threaded run a
multi-threaded run a multiprocessor even
run at multi machine right so the
benefit of being able to separate the
description of a computation from the
execution of the computation is we can
mix and match those when they meet our
when they meet the thing we're trying to
do and often symbolic computations also
have benefits for correctness so they
tend to encourage working with immutable
data structures which has lots of nice
properties and type systems also give us
a lot of the same benefits the
traditional compilers do right so if I'm
going to do some long computation that's
going to run on a server and go for five
hours and then the last thing it does is
try to add a string to a number and it
fails it's really annoying if you get
all the way through those five hours and
then find out that you had a bug and
you have some sort of compile step
between there then you can learn Oh the
last thing I'm going to do is going to
barf and I can catch that before I
actually wait the five hours for it to
fail so keeping all those things in mind
I'm going to tab over to a demo of one
way that I think you might think about
building this kind of expression
language in Python so believe that's
already been executed that I'm gonna run
it again to be safe so this is like I
said sort of the the simplest hello
world example for trading algorithms so
it's doing a dual moving average and the
ideas I'm gonna for every asset in my
universe I'm going to take 30 day moving
average a 90 day moving average and then
I'm gonna screen out assets where the 90
day moving average is shorter or is
lower than the 30 day moving average and
the intuition here maybe is that assets
with short with her short averages are
on the way up in some sense it's
probably not really a reasonable actual
trading strategy but it's a it's a
simple one for a demo kever ebuddy read
okay at this font size cool and so the
way this works right we have these
built-in factor objects I construct a
simple moving average object whose
inputs are US equity pricing clothes
this is also against symbolic there's no
data associated with this it's just sort
of an abstract object that is going to
get fed into the system that knows how
to actually load this data and I'm going
to say we had a window length of 30 when
the length of 90 and then I can use
Python operator overloading to do things
like construct a filter which is the
result of a boolean comparison between
all these results right so i can say my
30 day moving average greater than my 90
day moving average is my screen and then
i construct a pipeline object that
actually represents all the computations
that i want to do and again if I execute
this you know that happens basically
instantly no computation has happened at
this point I've just sort of built up
objects that know how to compute
themselves under the hood what this is
going to do is take all these and build
a directing directed acyclic graph that
represents the dependencies between all
my different computations and I can
actually visualize what that graph looks
like so if i say so show graph on this
it's going to spit out a nice pretty
visualization which says ok well get but
get the clothes prices for all the
assets to struck 30 and 39 day moving
averages feed that into an expression
that's going to do a boolean compare and
then everything in this bottom box ends
up being an output and our expression is
an output because we've specified that
as a screen which says throw away any
assets that don't meet this criteria
before you actually show them to me
and then I can take all that and pass
this off to an engine which says run and
it's going to churn through all of that
and spit out about 600,000 rose and what
I would end it would end up getting back
here is a hierarchically index data
frame so for every day I'm going to run
this computation and then I'm going to
get an index of equity objects which are
basically thin wrappers around integer
with some metadata tied to them and then
I get a column back for every one of
these computations that I registered so
i got my 30 day moving average in my 90
day moving average so we can sort of
scale this up and make it more complex
so i can swap out my simple moving
average with a V [ __ ] which now requires
two different inputs so view wap this
volume weighted average price and then i
can say well i can compute the percent
change of view wat between my 30 90 days
and it looks just like the numerical
code that you want to right here right
so I've got vo up 30 minus B up 90
overview op 30 and I can do things like
take the rank of all assets by the
percent change in V where I say
ascending equals true or ascending
equals false and I can also do things
like take the top 20 assets by view a
percent change and again the the results
of this all end up looking exactly the
same my graph is a little more
complicated now so I've got sort of
arrows going all over the place one of
the interesting things you notice that
those complex arithmetic expressions
actually get fused together so I don't
have an individual node for every like
binary operator happening there the
linear chains of of expressions get
fused into one single thing and they get
computed with a library called melmax /
that is designed to look at basically
numpy array expressions and optimized
away temporaries and do some other fancy
things and so you know I've got my view
up there getting in front of this
expression i'm taking a rank comparing
that to 200 this is these two nodes
actually correspond to that top call
that i had made and then I'm also just
getting the output here and again if I
take that and do run pipeline takes
slightly longer but not too much longer
and I get my rank back out as well as my
percent change one of the really
important ideas that happens here too is
that users should be able to extend the
system with primitives that behave
exactly the same way as the built-ins is
a great length there's a great talk by a
guy Steele called growing a language
where the central thesis of that is that
one of the really valuable elements of
programming languages are a really
important element of programming
languages is the ability for users to
add and extend the language in ways that
be
exactly like the built-ins of the
language and so you can create your own
custom factors and basically the kernel
of this is this is a compute function
that gets passed the current day an
array of asset labels an output array
and then an array of an umpire a
corresponding to the data that you
actually got passed in so here I'm
writing a custom factor that computes
max drawdown which is just saying look
over the last ten days and give me the
percent change from peak to trough for
each asset there and so I'm going to
construct a 90-day max drawdown and then
once I've constructed this object it has
all those same built-ins that we looked
at before so i can do ranking on that i
can also pass it i talked a little bit
about this notion of masking out things
when you do a rank computation so this
says compute view out percent change or
rank by view up percent change but mac
masks down to just assets that are in
the bottom two hundred by max drawdown
and if i run that again i get slightly
more complicated complicated graph and
will notice here to write that this
boolean or sorry this rank now has it
now has a dependency on this top 200
call which is saying that in order to
successfully compute rank with this
masking applied to it i have to have
first figured out how to which assets i
actually want to mask out in that
ranking operation and again i can do run
pipeline and i get all my values and
note that all the ranks are between 0
and two hundred because i only map down
to just those values so that's sort of
the basic API and how it works so
basically you know we can see that when
i define these custom fact is they're
all just getting past you know trailing
windows of numpy rays and so really all
that we need to do now to make all this
work is say well how do we just get
reasonable arrays of data into all these
computations subtitle this is how hard
can it be to get the last 30 days of
price and it turns out it's harder than
you might think unfortunately so there's
a couple things about financial data
specifically that make it more complex
to work with and you might otherwise
enjoy so companies are constantly being
created and destroyed so if we want to
naively just represent all this data is
like a big assets by dates array it's a
little bit tricky because we either have
to have lots of missing data or we have
to somehow chunk that up into pieces
that aren't wasting most of that space
splits dividends and mergers render past
and current prices and volumes in
comparable and restatements are
particularly thorny to do in any kind of
array oriented way so like I said assets
are constantly being created and
destroyed this is just a table of all
the assets in our asset database there's
about 200 or about 20,000 of them these
are just us equities so it's not that
big in the scheme of like total
financial data and looking at did we
think it existed on a particular day and
if we graph that we can see you know
they're sort of going up and down and up
and down in 2008 it wasn't a great year
keep going so splits dividends and
mergers or another fun problems so this
is just some code that's reading in the
price of Apple in 2014 and plotting it
and we you know very naively if we
looked at this day to be like oh my god
Apple tanked in the middle of 2014 and
of course in reality what happens at a
paleta 721 split in the middle of 2014
so everyone who held one share of apple
suddenly held seven shares and they were
all worth seven times as less so
nobody's the amount of value that
everyone held didn't change but suddenly
the price had this very big change to it
that you know is very obvious if you
look at the graph right everything
suddenly just tanked by a factor of
enough that you're going to notice more
subtle here is apple also paid a
three-dollar dividend in the middle of
May and that if you just look at the
graph isn't that obvious but that should
also be affecting things like return
calculations because you know between
this is actually the X date of the
dividend not the payday but at that
point in time a share of apple actually
just became worth three dollars left
because up until that three dollars less
because up until that point every share
of apple came with a promise of a free
three dollars at some point in the
future and so when you hit the X date of
a dividend you should expect the price
of an asset to tick down slightly to the
value of that dividend and that's
essentially the same problem as a split
except on a much larger magnitude and if
you're just trying to naively calculate
returns say you know you know you do a
one day returns as a percent change
you're going to get all these strange
anomalies in your data and this gets
more and more pronounced as you look
over a long time horizons right so if I
tried to do like a 30 day you know
backward-looking returns I'd have this
big long window of it like slowly
getting back to the right location
restatements are another phone crowd
so here's a hypothetical scenario on
march 5th apple announces that its
quarter 1 revenue was $15 that looks a
little suspicious to us but we're like
maybe they had an off off quarter and
then on March fifteenth apple issues an
amendment to say oh our quarter one
revenue is actually 15 billion dollars
and now our user asks us what was apples
quarter one revenue what's the right
value for us to return here and the
answer is it depends right and if we're
in a simulation on march forth the right
answer is I don't know because we didn't
have that data available to us on March
16th the right answer as far as we knew
is fifteen dollars and it's up to the
user to decide that that's probably not
a value that they want to use and then
on March 16th the right answer as the
battery that we actually knew and so all
these things are bringing us to this
question of how do we make sense of data
whose value we want to be sort of
thinking about differently from
different reference frames and one way
to think about is that you actually this
notion of like perspective all data
right where data whose value depends on
when you're asking the question so the
traditional solution to a lot of these
problems is to use what's called
adjusted prices and generally what this
means is sort of mucking with historical
prices so that they're comparable to
current prices and this is what you get
a few query like you Yahoo or Google
Finance api's so there's some problems
with adjusted prices though so one
problem is that they're non reproducible
in the sense that if I take the values
that Yahoo quoted me at 2014 and run a
backtest through 2012 and then I take
the same values that yeah or I take the
values a yahoo quotes me today for 2012
I'm going to have different numbers
piping through my algorithm and if
you've written your algorithm in the
same way you probably shouldn't be
making different training decisions
about those but it's still this problem
of reproducibility where if something
suddenly starts behaving differently
then you're not running it with the same
numbers and it's not obvious that you
know those things aren't aren't
affecting it it can also introduce some
sort of subtle biases so if a now go has
access to the real sproat the real price
and the adjusted price that it can tell
that a dividend or split is coming and
stocks that have undergone multiple
splits in the past will actually you
know between the point we're asking
about and now will have very low prices
in the class because they're being
multiplied artificially over and over
and it still doesn't help us with
restatements right even you connect
to get around some of these problems by
like adjusting to some fixed point in
the past and then the prices that you
see for now aren't meaningful you're
late are very different from the prices
actually now but you still can't handle
this problem of restatements right we're
faithfully representing restated values
sort of irreducibly requires that i tell
you a different value for something at
different points in time so we have this
problem right we're trying to reduce
down this data to a single data point
for a given point in time and that
abstraction is broken for us in the face
of all these issues right so we want to
be able to say you know the value for
data set forgive an asset for a given
time is blah we can't do that but what
we can say instead is that the value of
a given data set for give an asset at a
given time from some perspective has a
meaningful value and this allows us to
talk in a meaningful way about how do
you correctly calculate something like
returns on data that has these
adjustment and restatement problem so
you know we've looked at or we've talked
about okay well we maybe we want to have
this extra notion of dimensionality and
now the immediately thing we should be
nervous about is well if we just you
know blow up the dimensionality of our
data set then we've blown up the size of
our data by you know however big our
biggest look back window is which can
potentially be pretty large so sort of
some napkin math for the size of the
data set that we're looking at this is
all just a daily equity data and sort of
the most naive representation of this
you could have would be a big array
where you have you know a value for
asset ID open high low close volume and
date and then times the number of assets
times the number of dates and even then
it's like this there's immediate obvious
things you could do but then the most
naive representation of you that you
could have for this is about four
gigabytes skip that i think i forgot to
execute a slide up above but i don't
have time to go back for that right now
so we do some slightly fancy tricks
we're using a unjust data format called
be calls its compressed and chunked and
that lets us get lets us get the data to
about 300 megabytes the main things that
we're doing to make it smaller like that
is we don't store entries for dates
where they didn't wear an S didn't exist
we represent all the data is 32-bit on
site 32 bit unsigned int since Ted of
64-bit floats
obviously cutting in half cuts the size
of the data in half a little more subtle
thing that I thought was cool is that
integers tend to integers that come from
real world processes tend to compress
much better than floats because bit
patterns of integers that are near each
other tend to be more similar than bit
patterns of floats that are near each
other because of how floats and integers
are actually represented in the standard
ways at least and so you can often get
better compression by representing
things as integers rather than floats
and so the question is okay well we
don't want to just you know arbitrarily
blow this up to like some three
dimensional array that's ginormous we
want to build some data structure that's
that encapsulates this complexity and so
one of my like favorite programming
quotes of all time is this quote by Rob
Pike who's now one of the designers
behind go and he says data dominates if
you've chosen the right data structures
and organize things well the algorithms
will almost always be self-evident data
structures not algorithms are central to
programming and so we've done to make
this problem tractable as we've designed
this data structure called an adjusted
array and basically what an adjusted
array is just as a little buffer that
stores the the as traded prices of
various things are the as the as
reported values for like fundamental
stuff and then it also keeps around this
little dictionary of places to mutate
the data when I get to a certain point
so this says all right I've got the data
this is did for Microsoft and Apple
through the period that we were just
looking at and it says okay well here's
my buffer of data and then I also have
this array of adjustments which says
when i get to row 13 retro actively
change my view of the data i'm
multiplying it by 1 over 7 so this is
this is actually the sort of on the
metal representation of how we deal with
those splits and then I i can call
traverse on this and this produces a
window a window like a windowing
iterator object that again has this
buffer of data and then knows that as I
tick forward in time I need to retro
actively change my view of what the
world looked like and so here right the
splits show up is float64 multiplies but
you could also imagine having overwrite
objects for things like restatements and
then if i ate through this thing right
you can see the price is sort of slowly
ticking just sliding up the screen here
and what we should expect is that when
we get to the ninth which is when the
split occurs all the values you suddenly
tank by a factor of seven so that
they're comparable to the prices that
we're seeing
on the morning of the 9th but sort of
the curve and the shape of those prices
should be should stay constant that's in
fact what we see here that's suddenly
all these Apple values went for me about
602 being about 90 and then so that's
sort of the core data structure that's
underlying all this stuff and when we
actually query all this data at the
atomic terms of the graph this is what
we're firing out so there's a bunch of
future work that you know we still want
to build into this so i have a branch on
my laptop that's adding support for the
classifier stuff that i talked about we
also right now when we support
floating-point and sort of boolean data
so support for non-numeric data types
and particular dates are really
important thing for anything in the
financial domain so you want to be able
to say things like you know assets that
have earnings coming up or something
like that and then data sets that have
multiple entries per data point or per
asset per day so things like earnings
estimates calendars the whole long tail
of more exotic data figuring out clean
AP is to allow people to reduce that
higher dimensional data into data that
can work in this framework it's sort of
an ongoing project that if anyone has
deep thoughts on I would love to pick
your brain about and then longer-term
like I talked about a lot of the
benefits of symbolic computation come
from being about having being able to
have these different execution engines
right so you can imagine having a
parallel version of that algorithm where
right now I showed you all those
different graphs and basically what the
algorithm is you know jump through all
the entries in the graph and just
compute them by themselves a more
interesting algorithm for that might be
something like take all the nodes in
that graph start a thread that says wait
until our block until all my
dependencies are satisfied and then
compute me and that would allow us to
leverage parallelism for a lot of these
computations in a way that we're not
doing right now and then maybe further
down the road doing something like
just-in-time compilations of the factor
compute function so numbers are really
obvious thing that we could do there but
also maybe you know Justin done
compilation for something like site on
would be interesting avenue to pursue
that's all that i have talked about but
thank you guys for listening through any
questions I'd be happy to answer
yep yep just instantiate them doesn't do
anything so they're just objects that
know how to compute things so the actual
thing that causes computation to happen
is i say i've got this pipeline object
it has like a simple moving average
thing so i'm saying the columns of my
pipeline are going to be a 30 day moving
average which is computed by this 30 day
moving average object and then when i
actually say run pipeline on that the
columns that i passed here correspond to
the columns of the data frame that gets
spat out so that's built into the simple
moving average object so when I said
here inputs equals US equity pricing
clothes so that's just a symbolic object
I skipped over the slides that are
actually setting up like the i/o
machinery there so basically what
happens is you register a loader that
knows how to load the US equity pricing
that closed column and on cuanto pean
we've built a whole bunch of loaders for
things like Morningstar fundamentals and
psyche signal and X demise and all these
other sort of exotic data sets the US
equity pricing loader stuff there's
there's one that's built in for zip line
that reads that fancy be calls format
that I talked about a little bit yep
yeah so I mean for the splits mergers
and dividends cases they're all just
retro actively multiply everything
looking back by some value and then the
adjustments get represented as over
rights the tricky thing is make sure you
sequence those correctly because they
don't necessarily commute correctly so
you have to know what the semantics are
of whether you went and where the
override happens and that responsibility
gets delegated to the loader to do
correctly can you be a little more
specific sorry
yeah yeah so so the way that we
represent that stuff generally does that
stuff is sort of a different layer of
abstraction from the stuff I'm talking
about from so by the time it gets to the
stuff that i just showed here that all
just gets encoded as these like
adjustment objects but generally
speaking the strategy for that is we
have some we have this notion of like
the baseline and then an Egyptian of a
notion of like Delta's to the baseline
so basically we say like here's when we
first learned some valuable a particular
time period this is the entry we have
for that and then if we have some
amendment to that that gets represented
in a separate table that says here's a
you know a piece of information that
says we should actually change our view
of the world once we get to some point
in time yeah yeah yeah so there Jen
because you could represent it as just
like the best known value at every point
in time but then you're you're
duplicating most of the data right most
data doesn't get adjusted most days cool
well thank you guys all